all right no in-person workouts at the
scouting combine this year they're going
to do
i assume some sort of medical check but
they're not going to be on the field
they're not going to do the underwear
olympics
they're not going to do the thing that
generates some tv ratings at a time when
it's not football season
there will be individual pro days held
at the college campuses remember that
didn't happen last year
that was the first thing to go with the
pandemic they pulled the plug on the pro
days
so the scouting opportunities were
limited so instead of bringing
all the kids to a super spreader event
in
indy they're going to have the little
mini events where
i don't know all the coaches i'll bring
the super better event though yeah what
do you do
are you gonna are you gonna have the
scouts go go school to school or you're
gonna do some sort of virtual thing
i i don't know but uh it's it's gonna be
a very very different year
you know 11 months after the pandemic
started we're still seeing very tangible
impacts and we got the full season in
but that doesn't mean the rest of the
nfl experience chris is going to be the
same
no definitely not i mean this to me is
you know one of the intriguing things of
the offseason no
combine no back channeling
between agents and coaches and owners
and everything like that
no talking to your friends about who's
your sleeper guy that you think's really
a first-round talent that people haven't
realized yet
just all those things you're going to be
lost you know in conversation this year
you know the back end back room trade
deals that go on at the combine before
free agency started
all of that it's going to be a lot
different and if you can't look at
players in person mike
wow i don't know what to think there
that would be
really really tough the in-person
checkout is to me the biggest piece of
the puzzle
so to do like a a workout and if you
have to watch the resume
hey yeah you'll get certain things but
seeing what a guy
actually looks like in person is a
different experience than watching an
ipad or a tv
and and i think that's going to be an
interesting thing too and i've yet to
see any details whatsoever about how the
pro days will work
i just assume the way the world works
right now the travel will be limited i
can't imagine
having a head coach like a bill
belichick hopping around from alabama to
clemson to here to there on that
schedule that they're on and it really
is after the combine
it's it's uh one after another up until
the middle of april
until you you hunger down and get ready
for the draft now the coaches don't go
to all of them but there are scouts that
admit many of them if not most if not
all of them the big ones at least so
a lot of questions still to be resolved
and i'll tell you
the back channel communications that
happen at the scouting combine and they
don't even make any bones about it yeah
you'll run into an agent say yeah i'm
going to meet with the
the giants or whichever team i don't
want to i don't want to point
a finger at anyone but they all do it
they have meetings with
agents who represent impending free
agents and they
they they get an idea of who's
interested not and that's what happens
the agents leave indianapolis knowing
who's going to be making the offers when
that 48-hour window
opens to to engage in negotiations
they'll still find a way to do it chris
life finds a way i know they'll find a
way
it's going to be a lot of burner phones
possibly that's one of the reasons why
they like doing it in person
there's no record of the communication
there's no
call log that shows that you used your
cell phone to call
someone with the the giants or some
other team so maybe it's gonna be a lot
of track phones purchased over the
course of the next couple of weeks
by nfl agents and executives they'll
find a way to get in contact
yeah that they will you're right it's
the nfl is still going to go on
you know they're going to figure out the
right way to to do this and
do their best within this situation but
it'll be something to keep an
eye on certainly and yeah like i said
that's the thing that jumps out to me
more than anything is just the in-person
thing
and especially if you're a team that's
you know in need of a quarterback
you know you got to be there see these
guys see what they're all about is the
ball really coming out of his hand the
right way does it have the same power it
looks like it has
on tv all of that and then yeah are
colleges going to make these scouts who
are coming in from all over the country
get tested before they get their show
results of a negative test before they
do that
all that stuff's got to get worked out
and meanwhile we've got a vaccine
rollout that
is not moving as quickly as i think we
we thought but it's going to continue to
move and that will change the dynamic as
well
regardless the scouting combine is not
going to be the scouting combine this
year and you wonder what kind of
permanent changes
may happen because of it they've been
determined to take the thing to la
which is not going to be an ideal
central location from the standpoint of
you know the
the medical checks and and everyone
being kind of in the same place
indianapolis is perfect for it and i
just wonder
if they pull the plug on at one year are
they gonna be able to put the plug back
in especially if they try to move it to
a different city
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports